in June
in Saudi with Kristina's hope the Thor
lost a handle on the basket left were
driving to the risk he's grabbed right
there clearly a continuation on the
plane
in a Torres leeteuk crowd
seized last 19 points that's rude cloaks
Wow
what shows from the basketball gosh
[Applause]
as Jefferson throws it away Sabonis with
the steel surface how about this ball
movement and you got to love that
you know this ball has never really stay
and he divided his hands the board on a
second it's tough for the defense
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Tigers dangled 103 you see because
they don't switch he got Teague on his
back hip Russell has 14 points in the
fourth quarter what a big shot Bob big
time player Brooke
Morel got Street completely out of the
play Russell will get back behind the
three-point line seconds remaining I
want him to get the quick tool number 0
has got the ball you know anything could
happen and that anything did happen a
solidly London coming on their two game
losing streak
you can go home now here we go
that's like
[Applause]
[Music]
that was clear out as it is Davis is off
line shooting 500 by Westbrook
I think he Sue's off target come off it
just looked like a model goodness in
transition here man his cross over on
drew Holliday and he went left
Russ went right he just made it look so
easy
off the midcourt screen Cavanaugh's
he'll pull up he'll score one point four
seconds remaining
and the Thunder back on the high side
Westbrook a real estate and here Steven
Adams again just blocking and tackled
tacklin right there strategically how
about the brilliance of that high screen
double-teamed misses his first attempt
[Music]
[Applause]
backside of the bucket previous to
Westbrook and the Thunder putting the
exclamation point as that ball went
through the cylinder it's good in my
eyes folks Westbrook
helping the Thunder dominate the Utah
Jazz is how it's gonna be
get used to it Westbrook with the steal
jailbreak what a pass it's all over this
is what's so special about this guy
there's maybe one if not two guys that
can make that pass and literally it is
it's an unbelievable sideshow and under
fire on the depot McDermott to inbound
Gibson and Adams Russell pulls up at the
nail let's cause thunder on the high
side well let's say playoff hopes of the
Dallas Mavericks
with this bucket right here five none
other than Russell Westbrook got a
chance here we go Westbrook across the
pipeline
he's trash he fires nice cars that gets
the rebound right guy bringing the ball
up the floor and you know he's not going
to give it up and look how far behind
the line he was about three feet beyond
the three-point line Russell Westbrook
was when he took this shot in traffic
I'm still gonna pass out I mean just
nothing is safe when Westbrook has the
ball in his hand
and the game on the line he has
delivered time and time again folks
[Applause]
runners out of timeouts Adams gives it
back to raw speed
[Applause]
to a historic day
Westbrook gets the thunder the victory
at the pleasure all I can say is why not
42 triple doubles on the season and he
is the ball game like that the kids got
a heart he's got a heart bigger than
bigger than we know folks now there is a
final review from the NBA replay Center
if you coming in for Doug McDermott
I mean he's hi here Westbrook let's look
back that fall away it comes the other
way Williams finds a home I can't get up
triple and move at the terrific move by
Russell Westbrook City one great move
after another all dazzling in the open
court Russell West were putting on a
show here earlier the Russ grabbed him
on the play
[Applause]
well Russell has the three now four
steals he's found on the line
get the dog and listen to this crowd
there's a balloon he didn't get the car
nothing that's good could do this as
we've seen him so many times just put so
much effort in that play it has the
energy to come back don't bust loose
Westbrook checked by Snell he pulls up
[Applause]
about a quick three Raymond film put on
we got the ball Russ with Tony Snell
left a whole lot of room and from
distance
Russell Westbrook knocks it down to tie
the ballgame the Thunder has trailed the
fish here Jackson wrangled and hailed on
the floor Westbrook to the way
Westbrook Scorza to drag the dagger hit
does Shaq Romero's hurt here we go this
is the big shot and you know he knew he
had no time other than it was no time to
catch and shoot he released it almost
like he knew the time was about to
expire let me tell you some man hit that
back of that rim and if he moved to that
great call by the Thunder to isolate the
floor spread it and leave Westbrook
singled up with Garrett temple time or
second time this season that's a little
miscommunication as they play more to
the minutes together he'll know the heat
one dose got lots Cory block filled
Westbrook and filthy this is tough to do
as limiters at the rim
Casey needed the great defense force the
turnover Williams
[Applause]
jumped off the trampoline that how about
the long-playing but tears Ferguson from
pit times have we seen Russell Westbrook
doing this play to tears partisan and
Russ camp table while he was up there as
you could tell that's all of the emotion
stuff shrewder Leonard missed the follow
Russell with the loose ball they can get
the tie
Westbrook on the drive
[Applause]
hi folks now that is a hard push
Westbrook full speed splitting the
defender and a beautiful left hand
finished 38 points tonight for Russell
Westbrook to go along with 10 rebounds
and six assists but no bucket more
important and then this one right here
and from Toronto's perspective this is
exactly one of the situations why you
traded for Kawhi Leonard he's got to be
your home header to either create a shot
of its own or for others what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleacher
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content